[Music]
all right welcome back
so we are now solving gnarly integrals
using
complex functions and properties of
complex functions in the complex plane
like the cauchy integral formula
and what i'm going to show you now is
that you can actually solve
real valued integrals of a real function
x
f x by kind of extending them into the
complex plane and using these properties
so this is really cool
sometimes there definitely are
applications of this this is pretty
closely related to
the inverse laplace transform bromwich
integral so a lot of what i'm going to
show you here is going to carry over to
that case
but it's also just super interesting and
neat right this has been uh
something people have done for a long
time is solve these really hairy
real valued integrals using
extensions into the complex plane
so i'm going to kind of jump in
and the example we're going to do i
actually really like this example
because it gets a lot of concepts
going here
is we're going to solve the integral
from zero to infinity
of the function dx over
uh
x to the fourth plus
do i want to
do plus
a to the fourth or plus one to the
fourth i'm gonna do
plus one okay and you as a homework are
going to extend this so
you are going to as a homework this
might just destroy me because i have
notes here
as a homework you are going to solve the
problem dx over x to the fourth plus a
to the fourth for a generic a
but it's going to make my life a lot
easier on this tiny white board to do
this for a equals one okay so for a
i'll say you know for
a equals one is the case i'm going to
derive here but it really is totally
general it's not going to be a big deal
i might even derive it for a generic a
and then at some point when things get
gnarly i'll just say okay a equals one
okay
so uh
be prepared for that
so this is the function we're gonna
solve this is a real valued integral
from zero to infinity of a real valued
function
and the first thing we're gonna do
because this is an even function it's an
even function in x we can say that this
is one half
of the integral from negative infinity
to infinity
of dx over x to the fourth plus a to the
fourth
and where this is going to get really
interesting
is that we are going to
essentially
in the complex plane let's see if i have
enough space here so this is my real
axis and this is my imaginary axis
essentially what we have here
is we are integrating along this axis
from negative infinity to infinity
so the function we're trying to
integrate
is kind of you know along this direction
and so what i'm going to do is i am
going to essentially
kind of create a closed orbit that
includes this
and a large kind of radius circle
that's also going to include some poles
of the complex version of this
so what we're going to do is we're going
to look at the function uh
f of z
equals 1 over
z to the fourth plus a to the fourth so
we're going to take this real valued
function
and map it into a complex valued
function where if i looked only at the
real axis it would recover my real
valued function
and this
complex valued function
has poles at
this has poles
at
z so so basically z to the fourth you
know equals minus a to the fourth means
there's poles at z equals a
times
the fourth roots
of negative one
and i had a lecture earlier where i
showed you what all the fourth roots of
negative one are so if i have my complex
plane and i have negative one and i want
to know what its fourth roots are i take
its principal angle divided by four so
that's here
and then i have kind of the four
star
points that are you know
2 pi fourths apart from each other so
these are the the fourth roots of
negative one i said that pretty quickly
but i have a whole video on how to do
this
uh so the the fourth roots of negative
one
i'm assuming are going to be things like
uh
square root of two
um you know
plus or minus one
plus or minus i divided by root two
those are these four
these four
roots of negative one and so if i have
an a out front these are the four poles
so these are the four poles
of this function
a
times plus or minus one plus or minus i
over root two those are the poles
and what that means is that these are
poles at radius a in this star
configuration so they're gonna be like
here
here here and here they're on a unit
circle of radius a
and this is pole one pull two pull three
pole four
um
and for simplicity i'm just going to
call this you know a1 a2
a3
a4 where a1 is 1 plus i a over root 2.
okay that's that's my my definition here
and so what i'm going to do is i'm going
to say that the real integral i want
is essentially half
of what i'm going to do is i'm going to
define this large radius
contour cr
and this is my uh integral i actually
want we'll call this like uh c1 the
actual integral i want
is this integral along the the real axis
and so what we have what we're going to
do is we're going to compute
essentially we know
this whole thing so i'm going to do some
surgery here please bear with me so
this
plus this
we're going to call c
and this equals
uh so the integral of this closed
contour equals
the integral around
c1
plus the integral around
c r okay of
my complex function
so this closed curve where i do this
whole
closed curve
is equal to
the real value the integral along the
real axis plus the integral along this
big radius r curve
and what i'm going to do is i'm
basically going to take the limit as
that radius goes to infinity
which is going to mean that this c1
becomes this negative infinity to
infinity integral
and the cr becomes kind of something
that goes out to infinity and i'm going
to show you later that the cr
as the limit as r goes to infinity this
part of the integral becomes zero
and so this uh real part here is going
to be whatever the contribution of these
these residues are to this cauchy
integral formula so i'm gonna just start
solving it and i'm gonna try to recap
and tie back but we're gonna use a few
theorems here
we are building a closed loop
that contains two singularities so we're
going to solve
this big integral c using the cauchy
integral formula
that big integral c is going to equal
the integral i want on the real axis
plus this integral i don't want on this
big radius as as i take the limit as
that radius goes to infinity
and if i show that that radius r
integral goes to zero
then the integral of c one equals
whatever i get
integrating this closed loop around
those two singularities this is gonna be
a bit tricky i'm just gonna i'm gonna
get into it okay so
what i need to do first is i'm gonna do
this big integral c
let me try that
uh and i think this is going to be kind
of gnarly so um
i'll be super explicit here just just
real quick one more thing so this this
literally equals the integral from minus
r to r
of you know
d
x over uh x to the fourth plus a to the
fourth
plus the integral of this you know
radius r curve
uh d z over
z to the fourth plus a to the fourth
this thing equals
a closed contour around c
of dz over z to the fourth plus a to the
fourth and i'm going to take the limit
as r goes to infinity so this becomes
negative infinity to infinity the thing
i want and this is going to go to zero
so i just need to compute this thing
okay
all right um
and and this is going to be true for any
closed contour that contains these two
points for any radius that's big enough
that's bigger than a so for radius one
you know 10 or a million or you know the
limit as r goes to infinity this
actually isn't going to change because
of this kosher integral formula
so how do i do this
i think the key property here
is that this is equal to the integral
around this closed contour
i can factor this z to the fourth plus a
to the fourth this is z
minus a one
times z minus a two
times z minus a three
times
z minus a4
dz
and
away from a1
all of this other part of this function
sorry that was a mess
this is a z
away from z from a1
all of the other terms in this
expression are analytic away
i'm sorry our analytic at a1 this is the
only part of this function that's not
analytic at a1
similarly around a2
you know 1 over z minus a1 times z minus
a3 times e minus a4 that's analytic at
a2 the only part that's not analytic at
a2
is this part here
so we can use the koshi integral formula
to essentially say i'm just going to
start writing this down and hope that's
pretty close to right
this is going to be
i'm going to kind of shrink wrap this
around each of these and write this as
two different pieces
this is going to be equal to
an integral around this one and an
integral around this one i'll call this
c
a 1 and ca2
so this is the integral of ca1
of
the analytic part of my function
which is 1 over
z minus a2
times z minus a3
times z minus a4
over z minus a 2.
and again using this cauchy integral
formula
oh crud this is a one
i probably shouldn't do complex analysis
for six hours straight
z minus a1
uh so this is one part this is the
integral around ca1
dz
plus the integral around
ca2
of the part that's analytic which again
is 1 over
z minus a1
times z minus a3
times z minus a4
all of that over z minus a2
dz
let me just recap here i've taken this
big contour integral and again i can
continuously deform that so that it's
basically hugging these two
singularities
maybe with a tiny little you know
connector between them that's going to
cancel out
and so this is you know this big
integral around this closed loop is
equal to the you know shrink-wrapped
integral around this one plus the
shrink-wrapped integral around this one
because koshigorosa says i can i can
deform these continuously until i hit a
singularity
and so the integral around this a1 point
i'm claiming that of this big gnarly
function you know one over z to the
fourth plus a to the fourth
this part of the function is analytic at
a1 and this is the only part that's not
analytic so we've broken this down into
something that's analytic divided by you
know z minus a
and then for the second singularity
similarly these three parts of the
denominator are analytic so this is the
analytic part and this is the the
singular part
and so by koshy gorsa
this is pretty cool actually
this whole thing
is 2 pi i
times this whole numerator part
evaluated at a1
so times
1 over
a1 minus a2
times a1 minus a3
times a1 minus
a4
now you know this looks like a
mess but each of these a's are actual
complex numbers you can plug in a1 and
a2 and a1 and a3 and a1 and a4 and you
can chug this through on a big old piece
of you know graph paper and you'll get a
number a complex number out so this is
basically solved this is done this is a
number we can compute this pretty easily
i don't want to do it but we could do it
similarly here
because of the cauchy integral formula
this being the analytic part here and
this being the singular part is 2 pi i
times this analytic part evaluated at
the singular value
so plus
2 pi i
and only a little bit changes here now
it's you know
a
2 minus a 1
times a 2 minus a 3
times a
2 minus a 4.
and again i can kind of chug through and
and compute these
and
i have done it here
and so i'm just going to leave this as
an exercise you can download this pdf
and see like the nitty gritty carry the
root 2s and all that crap it doesn't
matter
what this equals
is essentially i get
uh
2 pi i
divided by
2 root 2 a cubed i
which simplifies to pi
over
root 2
a cubed okay
you i just all you have to do is plug in
a 1 a 2 a 3 a 4 into these expressions
and do you know
do the math with these a's and this is
what's going to pop out okay this is the
integral around this closed contour
for any radius r that includes these two
points for any radius bigger than this
than the radius a for any r bigger than
a
this integral equals this
so now all i have to show
is that if i take the limit as r goes to
infinity this term goes to zero
then the integral i care about
equals this expression here
so the last thing i have to do is show
that this integral goes to zero as r
goes to infinity okay i hope you're with
me
and in that case what we will have
is that
this will equal this
which means that the integral i care
about will be one half
of this okay so that that's what we're
going to show is that the integral
i care about this integral here is going
to be one half
of this
if
this uh
this other half the circular half
goes to zero as my radius goes to
infinity
i'm going to erase a bunch of stuff
so i am going to count on you to
remember or you can always pause or go
back and you know find this board later
i'm going to erase most of this stuff
and we're just going to show that this
integral goes to zero okay so maybe
here's what i'll do
is i'll keep
the punch line
of this right here so this
uh equals
over
root 2 a cubed and i'm going to erase
all of this stuff and then we're going
to show this last term equals zero so
okay
the last thing i need to show you now is
that this
big radius
part of my closed contour c
goes to zero as r goes to infinity
and we are going to
do that using the ml bound that i showed
you earlier it's a very intuitive
property so we're going to show that the
limit
as r goes to infinity
of the cr portion
of dz over z to the fourth plus a to the
fourth is going to equal
zero
and the way i'm going to do that how do
i want to do that um
is essentially using the ml bound so i'm
going to show that the integral around
cr
of dz over z to the fourth plus 8 to the
fourth
is going to be less than or equal the
norm of this
is going to be less than or equal to m
times l
where l is the length of this curve
which is
you know pi
r okay pi r is the length of this curve
so this is
pi
r and m
is going to be kind of the max value of
the function on this radius which i'm
going to claim is going to be something
like 1 over r to the fourth so it's
going to decay way faster than r
grows so
clearly the length equals pi r
and m
equals the max
over cr
of 1 over z to the fourth plus a to the
fourth which is less than or equal to
one over r
to the fourth clearly a is positive so
this can only be worse than one over r
to the fourth
and so m is you know one over r to the
fourth which means that this thing
is less than or equal to you know pi
over r to the third and as we take the
limit as r goes to infinity this
integral becomes zero this integral gets
smaller and smaller as i push that
radius out to infinity
so this entire term here this entire
term
goes to 0 as r goes to infinity
and similarly as r goes to infinity this
term
equals uh you know
twice
the value of the integral i want
so the integral i want here
equals
this quantity divided by two okay sorry
that is like completely illegible
this uh integral that i want
equals
this quantity
divided by two
okay this is i'm not going to do a super
recap on this
you know this had a lot of pieces the
synthesized all
of the integral theorems we learned in
complex so far we use koshi gorsa to
deform
our contours
you know in regions where they're
analytic we use the ml bound to kill
this big radius part as we took the
limit as r goes to infinity we use
cauchy integral formula to solve for the
closed contour surrounding two singular
points using this koshi integral formula
by computing kind of the two residues
and adding them up
and we solved for this half domain
real valued function by the fact that
it's even extending it to an infinite
real integral
in this framework pretty cool stuff this
is actually very very similar to what
we're going to do in
inverse laplace transform
where now what we're going to be doing
is trying to integrate
along a contour that goes kind of from
minus i infinity to plus i infinity and
we're going to create this big
bromwich integral and we're going to
integrate around singular points and
we're going to do something very similar
kind of knocked over on its side that's
how we're going to do the inverse
laplace transform using the broad much
integral all right stay tuned thank you